[Música]
para hablar sobre los temas más
importantes de economía me acompaña
Daniela Blandón Daniela cuéntenos por
favor en Buenos Aires las mujeres fueron
protagonistas esta semana de un foro de
la cepal porque tenemos que hablar de
este tema Hola Ángela pues mire se llevó
a cabo la décimo quinta conferencia
regional sobre la mujer de América
Latina y el Caribe a lo largo de toda
esta semana en Buenos Aires en Argentina
y uno de los temas más importantes tuvo
que ver con aquellas personas que cuidan
a otras Esta es una actividad
tradicionalmente desarrollada por
mujeres y de forma no remunerada o en la
informalidad por eso según las
autoridades reunidas en este país se
torna indispensable financiar y
formalizar el trabajo de estas mujeres
en un complejo contexto económico porque
tenemos los efectos de la pandemia
también la guerra en Ucrania veamos
primero Cuál es el panorama
estamos ante una crisis de los cuidados
que ya
era previa a la situación que teníamos
en la pandemia donde teníamos una
dimensión mayúscula de 16 mil millones
de horas diarias de trabajo en cuidado
no remunerado equivalente a 2.000
millones de personas trabajando 8 horas
diarias sin recibir una remuneración de
Gran desafío de convertir en trabajo
remunerado el trabajo no remunerado en
condiciones de trabajo decente en
promedio más de El triple del tiempo de
trabajo no remunerado
recae sobre las mujeres si comparamos la
dimensión que recae sobre los hombres y
además la pandemia también tuvo un
impacto particularmente fuerte sobre las
mujeres y especialmente aquellas mujeres
que se desempeñaban en el segmento
informal de la economía donde hubo una
destrucción mayúscula de empleos que
todavía no se han recuperado
completamente Cuáles han sido los
hallazgos estadísticos de la cepal en
torno al trabajo de las mujeres bueno
Estaba comisión económica para América
Latina y el Caribe lanzó un documento
muy completo que describe muy bien la
situación Y es que hay una gran
asimetría en la carga total de trabajo
entre hombres y mujeres y esto se nota
en el hecho de que las mujeres trabajan
más horas pero menos de forma remunerada
la pandemia del 19 generó un retroceso
de casi 20 años en los niveles de
participación laboral de las mujeres en
la región y esto limita todavía aún más
su autonomía económica ahora veamos
ejemplos de lo que trae este informe han
detectado que sólo el 35,5% del ingreso
laboral individual está en manos de las
mujeres y que el 38% de aquellas jóvenes
no estudian ni trabajan con remuneración
la asimetría se nota también en el
tiempo destinado al trabajo doméstico y
no remunerado que en el caso de las
mujeres es del 19,6% versus 17,3% que
gastan los hombres en de su tiempo para
estas tareas más del doble en el caso de
las mujeres sabe que es lo peor que esto
es un Secreto a voces y que no es
tampoco muy revelador que digamos eso ya
lo sabíamos es la vida diaria también se
analizó su participación política bueno
notaron que las mujeres ocupan apenas el
24,9% de los lugares electivos en los
gobiernos locales y esto se da por la
escasez de tiempo hay un dato bien
interesante y es que en 2021 las mujeres
ocupaban el
33,6% de los escaños en los parlamentos
nacionales en América Latina y el Caribe
se estima que a este ritmo tomará más de
40 años alcanzar la paridad en estos
órganos legislativos ahora las
autoridades han urgido a diseñar
políticas sobre todo en lo que se
refiere a la economía del cuidado que no
es más que formalizar a aquellos que
cuidan de otras personas la mayoría de
los cuales son mujeres
la pandemia evidenció la necesidad de
avanzar en materia de cuidados y las
previsibles contracciones económicas en
el futuro próximo que afectan
especialmente a las mujeres nos llevan a
pensar que la urgencia de desarrollar
sistemas de cuidados no hará más que
agudizarse en los próximos años Uruguay
inició el camino con su Sistema Nacional
de cuidados ya son varios los países que
están tramitando la normativa para la
creación de sistemas nacionales de
cuidados es el caso de Argentina chile
Ecuador Panamá Paraguay o México que
están mayoritariamente basados en los
recursos de los presupuestos generales
Daniela el cuidado es un trabajo y uno
de los más difíciles Sí señora de uno de
los peor remunerados Muchas gracias
muchas gracias a usted Por ponernos este
panorama que si bien no es desconocido
si es importante mantenerlo en la
palestra pública todo el tiempo nos
vemos en la otra semana con más noticias
económicas